だからお釈迦様は堂々と私もちゃんと田んぼを耕して生活しているんだと
はっきりと言ったんです
それで仏教は一応無常だ
無常しかいない人間にね
論理性わけのわからない人間には仏教はわからないんです
だから人間の言葉を使ってそれに乗せて仏教を語るんです
だから知りたい人は質問しないといけないんです
理解したい人は だから絶対質問しないと決めてる場合は
まあそれでいいじゃない
絶対理解できありません
理解しませんと こっちは苦しみのなかいるんだと覚悟しているんです
で それで質問することをこのバラモンは初めてお釈迦様にやったんです
この前も会ったことあるんだから
そんな侮辱的なこと言わないでよ
初めてやった 初めて会ったのに質問出したんです
それの答えには完全に仏教が当たってしまったんです
お釈迦様は 現代で何か質問ありますかっていうと
仏教勉強してないんだから
そういうことで質問がないんです
仏教勉強して私質問して
私はきちんと調べますからね
勉強して質問するっていうことは
私の知識レベルをチェックすることでしょう
いきなり大学の教授のつもりになってるんです
質問出して それに答えなさいと
それで私は答えた ああ OK
まあ正解です あんた百点で
まあ六十点だ この人間が無情な態度っていうのはね
質問は知りたいんだから聞くんだよ
このバラモンはね 私はもう田んぼを耕してそれを食べてるのに
なんで田んぼを耕してるのかと
それ自分の正直な気持ちでしょ
それ別に学問じゃんで
そんな そんな程度の質問に
それで私もちゃんと田んぼを耕してますと
あれ あんた牛もないし
土地もないし 何もないでしょうがないんですけど
それが質問なんです お釈迦様
私の世界では種っていうのはこういうものなんです
牛はこういうものなんです
土はこういうものなんです
道具はこういうものなんです
そしてスティックはこういうものなんです
それでかき混ぜる結果はこういうものなんです
それで結果出るまでやって
こんな結果になるんですよと
それでぴったり話ができたわけです
話は ということで ブッダの説法っていうのはほとんど一部以外
比丘たちに語ったところ以外は全部質問に答えている説法なんです
はい それでバラモンはもうやっぱりすごいと
この人はただ食べてるわけじゃないっていうことで
かなり立派なこのお祭りですからね
金で作った大きな鉢があったみたいです
かなり大きいものです
まあそれはまあ偉い人々はね
そこでみんな囲んでね
そこからご飯とか食べていたでしょうね
おそらく それであの普通のご飯ではなくて
ミルクを入れてご飯炊いて
それは金の鉢に深い鉢に入れて
この人たちはそれに全部ほとんどたくさんご飯を入れて
重いんでしょう それ持っていって
お釈迦様に差し上げたんです
お釈迦様はどうか召し上がってくださいと
もうこれは十分の答え
質問に答えたんだから
お釈迦様はただ食べてるわけじゃないんだから
ハッスルしてるんだからね
小麦を 稲を作っているわけじゃないんだからね
別なものをやってますからね
不死という境地を目指して仕事をしてるんだけど
それでまた助けているしね
そういうわけではいはいどうぞもらってくださいと言ったんです
言ったらお釈迦様がヤンニバワンゴートアマカンパランカシンカセと言って
ゴートのさんは不死という稲を刈るために農業
田んぼを耕しているんだと
だからもう食べてよろしいということ
お釈迦様がこう言うんです
ガータビギータンネアゴージェネリアン
私はね この歌って食べてるやつじゃないんだよと
まあ海外は歌でできましたからね
このたちまち歌わせてくれるっていうことは
知識人の間の能力なんですよ
で まあ歌ってったっていうのは
これは四行でね まじまじとまあ
あの 何ですか 音律って言ったっけね
あって あの それに合わせてとりますけどね
だからなんとか何か歌って
あの 何でしたっけ あの
ストリートパフォーマンスみたいな感じで
一曲歌ってそこでご馳走にもらうという
私はそういうことやりませんよ
サンパッサタンブラッハナニヤサダンマ
これっていうのは品のないことで
歌ってご飯食べるってこと
聖者にとっては品のないことだと
ガーターディティータンパニダンテブッダ
ブッダたちは歌っているものっていうのは断りますと
お釈迦様はお釈迦様ももうものすごい超越した知識人でもあったんだからね
軽々と歌うんですよ それもただの楽しみの歌じゃなくて
しっかりした もう経典ほとんど記憶できてるでしょうに
お釈迦様が語ったそのままでしょ
そういうことだから まあ立派な歌ですよ
あんたすごい上手ですよ
じゃあご飯ちょっと食べてくださいって言っちゃう
これではもう食べません
ダンネーサティブラッハナブッディレータ
これは我々の決まりですから
聖者たちの いわゆる説法の代わりにご飯は食べません
私はあんたに説法するんだからご飯ちょうだいと
あるいはあんたご飯くれたんだから
まあその代わりなんですけど
説法するぞと それはやりませんと
断った せっかく渡河に行ったんですけど
あんたのご飯いりませんと
それはお布施じゃないんですね
お釈迦様すごい立派にこの人を納得させたんだから
やっぱりあんた言ったことは確か
はい ご飯どうぞということが
これ食べてならば お釈迦様はバラモンを説得させてご飯食べたことになるんですね
お釈迦様にとってはすごい立場が悪いんです
もう品格に関わる問題になるんです
聖者としての清らかな生き方にはもう
ちょっとそれはないということで
それでアンニエーナチャケーリナンマヘセン
他の聖者たちを見つけて
ケーリっていうのは心清らかにして完成になっている
あの 聖人を見つけなさいと
キリマーサマ 煩悩なくなって
クックッチェウータサンタン
後悔することも何もないところに
後悔することもなく 煩悩全部なくなっている聖人
そちらでまた真理語って
断りながらも悟った人はどんなものか
敬愛に完全な人である
マヘーシー大なる聖人である
キナーサは煩悩はないんだと
クックッチェ・ウーパサンタン
後悔する気持ちというの一欠けらもない
消えてます 心から全部
そういう人へ人を見つけてアンネーナ・パーネーナ・ウパッタン
その人に食べるもの 飲み物で面倒見ちゃいなさいよと
ケッタン・イタン・プンニャ・ケッタッシェ・ホーチ
あなたにはそれは福田になるでしょうと
いわゆる功徳がどんどん
聖者が福田なんです 聖者がおすることによって
お布施した人はたくさん徳を積むことになるんです
だからといって もう説法のおかわり
だい 何でしたっけ？代償にはなりません
説法の代償としてあげちゃうと
これこそ三宝を侮辱することなんです
三宝を軽く見ていることですよ
ちょこっと説法を聞いてわかっただけでも
その人には今世で幸福になるし
来世で幸福になるし 善戒生まれるし
徳積むことできるし もし瞑想でも教えたならば
もう悟りまで開けるし
それはちょっとご飯で計算できるんですかね
だから価値を超えるものを与えてますよ
説法という形で  説法してるんだからご苦労様
はい これもらってくださいということはもう侮辱なんで
その代わりに  お布施をする場合は
これだって代償じゃないんです
だって本人がたくさん功徳積んだことになります
ということで お釈迦様はもう食事を断ったんです
ただ このバラモンはもうせっかくお布施しようと用意したものだからね
では これどうしました？このご飯は
したら この世の中では神々
人間 梵天 マーラ 悪魔の世界ですね
この生命 すべての生命の中で
これ食べる人はいませんよ
食べる資格ある人はいませんよ
だってこれ お釈迦様が仕事をしてもらったもんですよ
偉いのが 尼らが仕事した
尼らが袋 苦労して説法して
尼の苦労に対する代償でしょ
これ食べる権利は誰にもない
だから誰が食べてもこれを消化できません
ブッダのものだからね
結局は受け取らなかったんですけど
ブッダに個人的にあげた個人的な財産なんで
それは誰にも使う権利ないんだから
食べたら消化できなくなります
死にますと だからまあ
食べる 食べてもお腹は消化しない
体は 細胞がそれは分解しない
それって命に関わりますからね
しかし アンニャーテパターハゲタって
尼だったら食べられますと
もう断りましたけど 食べようと思ったら別に食べられます
あるいはサハーゲタッサーワと
あるいは私の弟子たちなら食べてよろしいと
それはお釈迦様の弟子たちも阿羅漢ですからね
まあ それでも食べてもよろしいし
阿羅漢でなくてもお釈迦様の弟子たちだから
で 自分たちで分けてください
自分たちに与えな これは大丈夫と
お釈迦様の弟子たちだから
だから尼か尼の弟子以外は誰にもこれは消化できませんと
ですから このご飯をね
緑のない土のところに捨てなさいと
草も生えてない 草一個も生えないぐらいの土地ということは
虫もないんです  そういう土地ってのはあまりないんですけどね
でも 溶岩とかあるところで
ほとんど草も生えない
生えないところがあるとしたら
虫もないんですからね
そういうところに捨てなさいよと
それもあるしね あの まあ草の上でね
ご飯なんか溢れちゃうとね
草が死にますからね 結局は
あるいはアッパーナキワ・ウダケ
何 誰も住んでない水の中に捨てなさいと
どこかの水の中に捨てなさい
水の中でもいっぱい魚やら蛙やらいっぱい水ヘビやらいるんだったら
そっちに捨てちゃだめだと
捨てなさいと言ったんです
その時アトカシバラドゥアジュガラムタンパレハンアッパネグディオピラジ
それでまあ水に捨てたんですよ
水に捨てたら そのご飯は音を立てて弾けていったんです
で こっちはそこは丁寧に書いてます
アトコソウパヤサウデゲパッキトチッキタエテチキチタエテサンドゥーパエサンサドゥーパエ
音まで書いてます ビリビリビリビリと音を立てながら
全部こんな弾けて弾けて弾けて弾けて消えてしまった
大量のご飯 で たとえ話もあります
もっと説明すると 一日中鉄板何かをね
太陽に当たったならば
ものすごく熱くなっているでしょう
そのうちに水ちょこっとちらっと入れちゃうと音を立てて消えちゃうでしょ
そんな感じであの水に入れたご飯が弾けて弾けて弾けて消えていったと
バラモンが怖くなりました
これ見たら これ大変なことだ
ありえないことでしょ
で 弾けていったのは これは誰にも食べられないようなんですよ
それはお釈迦様慈悲でもあるしね
食べたらもう大変なことになる
で このバラモンがものすごく怖くなって
手が勝手まして もう仏教の真理もわかったでしょうし
本当の道に本業は何やともわかったでしょうし
その上やっぱりこれすごいと
あれ あの現象見て怖くなって手が勝手まして
で この怖くなったっていうことは
自分たち何やってるのかと
こんなくだらないことをして
自慢までしてきたんだから
もう田んぼぐらい作れることをお釈迦様までぶち壊しちゃったんだから
仕事は自慢するもんじゃないやと
道っていうのはこの型の道ではない
一切の苦しみを消えることが道ではないかと
ただ米ちょこっとそこでだけ自分がどんな態度取ったのかというのも情けないし
惨め それが怖くなるという単語で仏教使ってるんです
でお釈迦様にまあそれで礼をして初めて
でよくわかりました 目が覚めました
暗闇に光が当たるような感じで
ブッダの言葉でお釈迦様は智慧の光で現れましたということで
出家を願い出て その場で
いかにすごいかというとね
あれほど派手に祭りやった人が
何のことなく出家しました
だからそれってもう普通の人間たちがそれまで勇気あると
言うわけないでしょう
私は偉いバラモン だからね
牛五百頭連れてきて田んぼやってますから
かなりの人間ももうもう最低五百人いるでしょう
もっといるでしょうね
田んぼに 千人ぐらいで自分がリーダーでしょ
自分の財産でしょ そんなのはどうでもいいと
財産とか家とかね 出家するぞって言って出家するんです
まあ出家して まあそれで修行して
間もないうちに完全たる阿羅漢に達しましたと
それで全ての苦しみは無くなった
ところで教典は成就になった
はい では話は終わりです
どうもありがとうございます
[拍手]